[Music]
a weekend of traditional music in the
mexican capital
[Music]
the event is son paramilo a cultural
festival that highlights the great
diversity of mexican folk music and
perhaps more importantly a perfect
excuse to bust a move
we feel a tremendous pride because this
music style is from our region in mexico
we enjoy dancing to it because we like
to represent our state wherever we go
son paramilo began as a way for artists
to honor beloved mexican choreographer
emilio rojas-aragon who passed away in
2002. today the festival has grown into
one of the city's most important annual
cultural events
one that encourages visitors of all ages
to hit the dance floor
this year the sun paramilo cultural
festival is celebrating its 20th
anniversary the occasion has drawn some
80 different musical groups and
performances representing nearly every
corner of mexico
[Music]
one of the most attractive aspects of
the festival is watching visitors
proudly donning traditional attire
after being shut down for two years due
to covet 19 restrictions the festival
has made a big comeback giving visitors
an introspective look at cultural
heritage through more than 30 genres of
mexican folk music
what if communities all around the world
turn to look at their own traditions the
cultural wealth of latin american
countries is immense but we're often
forced to listen to just one type of
music like reggaeton which is horrible
event organizers say they hope the
festival will continue to grow and
attract more international visitors who
are curious about the great many customs
and traditions that make up mexican
culture
manuel rapalo al jazeera mexico city